it's a hillbilly way of saying back that
thing out bootylicious probably about
trucks beer hopefully they're not too
against country well let's see what we
got here
BuzzFeed take one does every great
country star grow up on a farm
no I didn't grow up on a farm so yes are
you so maybe yes I grew up in Southern
California
country music spans the whole globe and
it could come from anywhere
what does honky tonk badonkadonk mean
well this is somebody that knows country
music booty honky doll but Duncan dunk
the well-proportioned but they're a
single dirt brother ha ha
they're single dirt road every country
star has to visit before writing a song
that is a great question yes there's
this one specific dirt road in Nashville
and itself about two miles south of town
no any old dirt road booze you sing a
lot about being down by the river is it
better than being down by the beach the
river is pretty fun that's when you're
younger and you don't live by a peach I
am from Florida so I have many more
songs about being by the beach than I do
being by the river why does every
country song have to mention in Traktor
beer boots or kicking up the hey what
the hell are you listening to you think
I'm sure I'm wrong but I've never heard
the expression kicking up the hey life
there's lots of tractors beer [ __ ] a
great sauce teeth there's actually more
to it now
somebody needs to die somebody needs to
get laid and you gotta say something
about you mama those are things that are
in every country song
why whiskey uh-uh cuz whiskey is awesome
like it gives you that weird warm
feeling inside and then we're gonna go
out there man hit the old pinot noir do
a little too snippet just then it's not
right does it
does Jesus always have to take the wheel
well I sure hope we don't get my start
to have an accident
we'll see who DUI yeah and if you've
been drinking I'd rather have Jesus take
the wheel than anybody I know the Jesus
always have to take the wheel no that's
up to you the end of your songs mention
a cat or are you really all just do I
could answer that so many ways I am a
dog person
you don't think of cat be loyal and
wonderful dogs are very loyal creatures
and I just don't like cat so I can't
speak for the rest of country music all
you non country fans out there I guess
that's like maybe two of you we're a
good blend of everything around now I
pull from all the top 40 hip hop songs
pull from all the classic rock stuff we
aren't all thinking about picking up
chicks and putting them in the truck bed
I really think it would make sense for
me to do that
you like lyrics about real people in
real situations maybe you should listen
to
I found country music because I had an
older sister who hated it one day trying
to be an annoying little brother I
turned it on and Tim McGraw don't take
the girl came on and I fell in love with
country music I don't know what the
natural inclination to push back against
country music is but it's timeless and
it's not going away so give it a shot
those are funny questions excellent I
actually have the same questions
[Music]